maternity wear please pregnant rihanna
is serving high fashion and we can't get
enough
work work work work work
work work work work work that's the 33
year old singer rocking a sexy ensemble
stepping out in beverly hills along with
her baby bump on full display riri
sports a black carhartt jacket lace-up
sweater black leggings and a pair of
stilettos and to complete her outfit the
mama to be rocks gold chains down her
belly similar to what she wore in her
pregnancy announcement obviously i'm a
confident woman so whatever i do it's
going to be confident this is the first
public re-reciting since she and her
beau asap rocky announced they're
expecting their first child together and
just last week a source told et that the
couple who's been dating since 2020 is
excited about bringing a little one into
the world
she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents our source says the two are so
happy
quote rihanna has always wanted to be a
mother and have children she thinks asap
is going to be the best dad it's amazing
and i'm honestly truly blessed real you
know
since the announcement their famous pals
have been sending love their way
including rihanna's longtime friend gigi
hadid who riri hand-picked to model her
latest savage x fenty collection i'm so
excited i can't believe it but the model
caused a stir with her well wishes when
the grammy winner showed off her growing
baby bump on instagram last week gigi
commented three angels
fans immediately went wild thinking
rihanna is expecting twins but days
later the 26 year old model clarified
her words adding i just caught word of
this commotion i meant re-rocky baby one
thing's for sure the rapper has been
riri's rock throughout pregnancy
[Music]
a source tells et quote asap has been
tending to all of rihanna's needs and
they are really enjoying this moment
together as a couple rihanna and asap
have such a strong bond and they can't
wait to experience parenthood together i
couldn't tell you how happy i am but
interestingly enough things didn't
exactly start out on a romantic note
between the two
[Music]
in a hot 97 radio interview from 2013
that's now resurfaced asap plays a game
of smash or pass and when asked about
rihanna he said this rihanna
uh
i might i'll pass on this it'll be easy
yeah let's watch that again how fast on
that right okay but don't worry the
rapper explains why not just because she
the homie i gotta explain because she's
cute you know what i'm saying
fast forward to 2022 and that friendship
grew into love and a baby sky's the
limit no rules